[Music]
hello hello is this Alf Foster very good
okay out you don't know me but in a way
you kind of do cuz my name is Alf Foster
as well oh yeah I just happened to see
your name in the phone book and it's the
same name as my own isn't that weird
yeah so I was thinking you know maybe we
should you know somehow meet or get
together at some point could check out
what that's all about
like I happen to call another Alf foster
this morning and he came over my place
here get on the phone now
hello yeah is this our foster yeah this
is our foster - we got three al postures
here this is gotta be the first time in
the whole history of the world it's
three al Fosters we're talking on the
telephone at the same time what do you
do al well mostly in the farm and like I
say that is so weird
I grow sorghum yeah I think we should
make a deal between the three of us but
because we are all three al Foster's
we'd be best friends forever
I would I definitely would I love it
you're my favorite al you're my favorite
it's really strange I come over here no
can you just hold just one second just
hold on one second oh yeah right there
right there now where where did you say
the other Fosters are from there I'm
over in the Lansing area over there no
just one second one second now hey if we
all got together and moved in together
you know what that'd be a foster home
okay okay I'm close I'm close this is it
Hey how can you just hold on one second
please
this is it
all right but well I gotta say it's been
great talking oh yeah I've kind of stay
friends with all four can we agree that
we will be best friends forever
one just one more question just throwing
it out there and there's been so many
coincidences coincidences today that I
think of it you know it's are you into
dudes at all oh yeah it's neither
we don't know all right okay talk to you
later
you